it seems reasonable to me that my
experiences with anti-semitism as a
jewish person would be relevant to the
conversation it would be hard to argue
that they're not particularly if nobody
else really has any personal experience
to add that seems very reasonable to me
i think where it goes too far and where
i've been critical of it is if i use my
identity to silence the other nine
people to say that their opinions don't
matter shouldn't be considered or are
fundamentally flawed and to suppress
others on the basis of asserting my
identity that's what i think is
destructive about identity politics
david pakman welcome to the show
thank you
i wanted to bring you one to kind of try
and get an idea of the landscape between
left and right at the moment and get an
understanding of the internal situation
on the left i know you're someone who
talks across the aisle quite a bit so i
figured you'd be a uh a good candidate
to try and help me work out what's going
on
sure uh i mean uh i guess
it would be good to know maybe a little
more specifically which which aspects of
it um i know that even
what is considered to be
the landscape of the left
would differ depending on one's
perspective as to what's part of the
left and what are the goals and
priorities yeah so my understanding is
that there's a movement on the left away
from a focus on identity and
some left-leaning thinkers are sort of
grappling and working through the
challenges that are associated with that
do you have any sense of this
i think that the idea that it's a move
away from it is maybe not the right
framing i think that there's been um a
contingent of the left that that i think
is actually really
the bulk of it um of which i consider
myself a part that has never been about
identity politics
etc right there's this kind of package
that that follows
um i think that
the voices that were in favor of
focusing on things like identity
politics and oppression olympics etc and
i understand that's a pejorative term
but i think we all sort of understand
what i mean
um i think they were over represented
for a period and appeared to be far
bigger than they were
reasonable people can disagree for sure
i know that whenever i make a commentary
like this
there will be people from the right who
say
you're completely wrong the left has
been completely taken over by that and i
say no no you think that because of what
i'm describing
um but i think that particularly
i think the 2020 primary on the
democratic party in the u.s was actually
a really important signal to a lot of
people
that looking at twitter and looking at
reddit
certainly would make one believe that
that wing is far bigger and far more
powerful than it actually is
and um for all of the great things that
i've said about bernie sanders for a
long time and supported him in primaries
i was
suspecting that his level of support was
much higher
online
than in reality i think the 2020 primary
really showed that it was not by a
little bit that joe biden won and for a
lot of people on the left that started
to
um open their eyes to the fact that
the left is a little bit different than
what it seems when you look at what the
internet would tell you
yeah yeah and i i think i see it as a
healthy thing actually because no matter
what you want the left to be
if you don't understand what it is it's
unlikely you'll be able to have
meaningful conversations it's unlikely
you'll be able to affect the change you
want even if you and i don't agree about
the change we want to see if we don't
accurately assess what it is it'll be
tough to go further we saw this in the
uk if you looked before the last general
election at twitter and the internet at
large you just thought this is going to
be a complete landslide for labor and
they lost by the biggest basically the
biggest margin in recent history
and
yeah it's so
you realize the asymmetry in terms of
the loudest people online
and where the biggest chunk of the voter
base is like normal people what's
affecting
normal people
yeah and one of the things that's kind
of a bummer about i did this segment on
my youtube channel a couple months ago
called i effing hate politics or why i
think hate politics or something like
that
and what i explained was
everything now has to be
um sort of like a toxic conflict and
even the things i've said so far to you
which to many people will sound just
sort of like we're just kind of
establishing a basis for the
conversation that's to follow
people will write to me and say
you gleefully cheered
that bernie didn't win the democratic
primary like in this interview that you
and i are having right now
and it's like no i didn't do that i
expressed and i expressed a fact which
was
there was a sense among many that that
wing was much larger than what it really
was that that's all i'm saying and it's
so toxic that it becomes hard to even
say some of these things yeah i mean
this nut-picking is something that i
really want to try and get into because
you get misrepresentations from both
sides the right will pick the most
outrageous outlandish story that it can
like anything that's on libs of tick
tock right and then just there you go
there's your content for the week you
can just react to that or if you're on
the left sometimes there's selections
that occur from the the point of which
like the dave rubin clips fails channel
or the whatever like this ridiculous
idea from some creator on the right
might be like you end up having
the
most unrepresentative
elements or the worst showings of both
sides you know the interview that
someone does where they just get it
wrong they just get the wrong thing out
there but this is representative of the
entire movement at large and the same
thing goes with
libs of tick-tock is like a small
microcosm that you can extrapolate out
to the entire movement of the left
yeah i think that there's a degree to
which that's true what i want to at the
first opportunity to get this on the
record i will take it
um i am not like of both sides-ism type
guy where i'm gonna say okay there's
extremism on both sides and there's bad
faith actors on both sides and
everything's the same
i i think that um
what's happening with the american right
wing
is um dystopianly horrible i mean truly
and i think that you're you're right in
that there are people who just get facts
wrong on both sides there's no question
about that
but um i mean particularly in light of
the pandemic we've seen the american
right which is the right i'm most
familiar with different countries have
different things going on
we've seen the american right
go into something that even many
republicans
don't recognize because it's so divorced
not only from reality but from morality
and from even their stated desires for
freedom and liberty into straight up
authoritarianism and i'm glad to talk
about that how would you what are some
of the what are some of the things that
you're referring to though
i mean we could start with the pandemic
right actually i think let's maybe even
go back
one of my critiques of the american
right for some period of time has been
that there is a sort of obsessive stated
focus
on principles
but they don't really care about the
principles they care about the
principles insofar as they help to
justify the policy that they already
want it's a sort of
confirmation bias of principles
and very quickly when the principles
start to contradict with the policy that
they want
they abandon the principles by saying
well this is different in this way so we
can look at the the pandemic to give us
some examples
the idea
of businesses should be allowed to
essentially regulate themselves
government should stay out of the way of
business
business by virtue of
markets
determining
what consumers want
should mostly be able to do whatever
they want and if they do the wrong thing
they'll be punished by consumers
consumers will say we're not going to do
business with this organization or that
organization great many businesses
decided we are going to make all of our
employees be vaccinated or be vaccinated
or have to get a weekly test or as fox
news has done be vaccinated or get a
daily test
um
or we are going to say our customers
must be or whoa
we need
laws dozens of laws in order to prevent
businesses from doing that well hold on
a second guys i thought your principle
was
let businesses do it as long as it's not
illegal
and it's not it doesn't appear to be
illegal for businesses to require
vaccination of workers or customers as
long as it's not illegal
let the market sort it out if the people
really don't like a business's vaccine
policy they'll go somewhere else right
they've abandoned that principle why
well because they only cared about the
principle when they saw it as a conduit
to the policy and behavior that they
wanted this is one example we can talk
you know there's there's many others but
this is the gist of what i'm talking
about yeah i get that going back to the
the identity politics uh point for a
moment do you think that that was a
strategic error on the left to allow
that to be the how would you say
uh part of the dominant messaging at
least online for a while but the the
goal here is to try and bring more
people on board and working people
identity politics isn't necessarily
applicable to many or all of them so
is that something that people need to
get past in order to be able to bring
more people into the fold of the left
i sort of find your framing um with
total peace and love i say this not
completely accurate in terms of what
happened i mean i'm glad to give you my
view on identity politics i don't ever
think it was the dominant
thing i i think that
for many of these attack the left
venues on the right they were acting as
though it was the thing and there's no
question
that i mean listen i was uh i was a big
critic
of the women's march for example
and the way in which they used identity
i felt as a cudgel for as an example
saying
jewish women
are privileged
and so they can't be in the leadership
uh that to me seemed like a microcosm of
the worst of the worst of identity
politics i was very very critical of
that uh they jewish women weren't
intersectional enough for example like
that stuff i think is terrible it's
terrible and i've been a critic of it
since day one but it never really has
been i mean for me in in my circle which
is a pretty
you know it's like you you stop
at socialist and you come back to the
center a little bit that's my that's
right that's a big swath not socialist
but
left
um it's economic policy it's
environmental policy
uh it's sensible taxation sensible
business regulation
not regulating more than is necessary
but recognizing that some regulation is
necessary it was never the big thing it
was quite frankly an annoyance all along
so you would say over the last year that
the focus hasn't been on on identity
through the black lives matter riots and
some of the reckonings that we've seen
with regards to sort of gender identity
and these crazy stories because what
you're showing is you're um
not necessarily your echo chamber it's
your job to be outside of your echo
chamber but i'm certainly showing mine
i'm certainly showing my perspective of
what i get fed which is often second
hand delivered to me perhaps by creators
from the right
well i i've never heard the term the
black lives matter riots before other
than on platforms like oan and newsmax
which are sort of like conspiracy like
so that is interesting that you would
call it that
i remember them as
when i think about the riots over the
last year i think of january 6. that's
really those are the riots really i
remember
black lives matter protests i recall
that there were no doubt some instances
of destruction of property which i
wholeheartedly condemn and believe
people should be
punished for right because i'm a
law-abiding citizen but i've never even
heard them described as black lives
matter riots they were overwhelmingly
peaceful compared to for example january
6. so i think as you're saying that may
be reflective of where your
some of the
messaging yeah yeah yeah that's an
interesting one
i guess to maybe go back
if it's interesting i can tell you my
view on the whole identity politics yeah
very much so
so um
my view is that
we have to recognize anybody
who
understands even a little bit about
culture and society and economics and
all these different things
would have to concede that one's
identity is really important in that it
is who one person is
and experience is shaped by identity
so for example if there's a discussion
about
anti-semitism
amongst 10 people and nine of them are
not jewish and i'm there right and i'm
the tenth and i'm jewish
um it seems reasonable to me that my
experiences with anti-semitism as a
jewish person
would be relevant to the conversation it
would be hard to argue that they're not
particularly if nobody else really has
any personal experience to add right
that seems that seems very reasonable to
me
i think where it goes too far and where
i've been critical of it is
if i use my identity
to silence the other nine people to say
that their opinions don't matter
shouldn't be considered or are
fundamentally flawed
and in uh and and to suppress
others on the basis of asserting my
identity that's what i think is
destructive about identity politics
but to simply say
identity is what affects our experiences
in the world
um to say it's of no relevance seems
like a hard case to argue
i think what's interesting here is like
we were talking about seeing online and
presuming that a particular vote may go
one way or the other based on an
asymmetry of how we've seen things
i think that perhaps there is an
asymmetry of how i have seen the left
if this is if you're providing an
accurate representation here that it has
still been about economic policy and
trying to bring people out of poverty
and so on and so forth like fundamental
left leaning ideas right to do with
class inequality like if that's been the
case
that's just being completely whitewashed
almost entirely whitewashed from what
i've seen
yeah i mean you know this is one of
those things where i don't speak for the
left and there will be many people who
will say david you can't speak for the
left because you're not a socialist for
example for some on the left the the
litmus test for whether you're truly a
leftist is whether you want socialism
right so i failed that test i feel like
this so i think it's very tough
i i don't even pretend to speak for the
left what i can tell you is kind of
where i am
and
as reflected by my audience most of my
audience is in a similar kind of place
there's there's socialists in my
audience as well
there's marxists in my audience as well
there's people more to the center
but
shows like mine and similar shows
don't really have like the full-on
identity politics communist uh socialist
audience that's sometimes caricatured
um so yeah i mean it's just i guess i'm
a little bit struggling because
my view is just my view
and it's not meant to say
i represent what the left is you know i
think you've got a good perspective of
what it is though i think if there was a
an overwhelming identity politics
slant to what fundamentally people on
the left are trying to achieve then
it seems like you're not seeing it from
your position at least no i think i mean
listen if you said where am i seeing it
most right
i would say i agree that in in higher ed
and academia that's an area where it's
much more
prevalent
but
in the left-leaning
union
and and
blue-collar employment sort of area
you know
you union steel workers in michigan who
mostly vote
for democrats and consider themselves to
be on the left and they want represent
democratization of the workplace and
they want
benefits and a fair wage and collective
bargaining
they're not big on identity politics
they're not big on critical race theory
they're not you know so so it really
depends on where you're looking and i do
think that
these things do exist they exist online
they exist in real life in some academic
circles etc i don't think there's i have
no interest in denying that but i think
the degree to which they're really
guiding
democratic party policy in any serious
way is is minimal so would you say that
one of the characterizations from the
right is that a focus or an obsession
with identity politics is causing
the left to lose touch with
working class normal working-class
people this was one of the criticisms in
the uk to do with the general election
that there were these red walls that
typically had been labor strongholds and
they were lost and they were very
working class areas and the argument the
justification from the right was
an obsession with identity politics and
intersectionality has lost them it's
this bourgeois academic movement
uh is that what's your sort of view on
that characterization
i think that that characterization would
be completely accurate
if only applied to those to whom it
really applies yeah and i think that's
an overwhelming you know overwhelmingly
small share of uh i mean these these
issues have uh you know a couple years
ago these were much bigger issues even
on my show
but um at this point it's just it's just
not even really coming up identity i
used to talk much more about identity
identity politics etc interestingly
right now
identity politics is coming up far more
when we look at what the american right
wing is doing
i mean these these movements around um
they want to uh the white great white
replacement which even tucker carlson on
fox news has recently kind of toyed and
played coy with uh immigrants are making
us poorer and dirtier and they want to
replace us
that is extreme right-wing identity
politics which arguably starts to border
on white nationalism that's that's on
the right that's that's a form of
identity politics
um the christian
um
oppression movement
under obama there was no merry christmas
but under trump it came back but under
biden it's gone none of this stuff is
true but it's all based on christian
identity it's it's identity politics
um it's just that on we on the left
if if we on the left wanted to do with
that what the right has done for so many
years we could talk about it all day
it's just very boring to me but a lot of
these movements
are a fundamentally right-wing identity
politics movements it's interesting
the framing that i had coming in here
was uh maybe i'm ahead of the curve here
maybe this identity politics stuff that
i'm continually seeing maybe that's it's
on the way out and i'm going to kind of
get my way in but it seems like you're
saying that's already that horse is sort
of already gone the identity politics
from your perspective has now been down
regulated from where it was what two
years ago when was it its peak
the the thing that's tough about this is
i don't know that it was ever really
at a determined peak
it was just the discussion of it was
getting more attention and i think in
the aftermath of the 2020 democratic
primary as the focus became hey you know
what joe biden won and won by a lot and
now what most of the left wants to do is
defeat donald trump
it's
the discussion of it has just become
very secondary and tertiary
i don't really know that as an issue
it's it's gotten better or worse you
know you get these stories of
um certain people aren't allowed at the
um
latino student union
because it's supposed to be you know
it's like okay and then we talk about
that and then we have like the same
conversation that becomes very popular
among
um the usual suspects online and like do
we do we ever really resolve anything i
don't know maybe like
certainly those things are still going
on but at this point it's not really a
serious part of the movement for
getting people access to health care um
figuring out what's what makes sense to
do with the minimum wage
what do we have to do about all the
different issues that are facing us
right now i find them to be a
distraction i would agree i think that
it's an own goal for both sides or
whoever is on the left that is focusing
on this whether this be a fringe
unrepresentative very vocal majority and
what it's doing is it's capturing the
right
so any cultural commentator on the right
hasn't had to create their own content
for
a long time at least two years because
all that you've needed to do is just
find whatever the craziest story of the
week is or the day and then you do a
reaction to this and you say look this
is this is how ridiculous and and
crazy this is what they're trying to
push to our
pick group
children families workplaces sports
teams
heritage
whatever um and i think that it's not
tremendously good for either because
it's just this kind of like endless
groundhog day cycle where nothing
actually gets achieved the people on the
right spend so much time reacting that
they don't get anything pushed forward
and they never engage
properly as it would seem with the
talking points that the left is
genuinely focused on at the moment
yeah i i just just this morning uh
before before we did this interview
i saw a screen cap from fox business not
even fox news fox business and there was
a 13 year old girl being interviewed
and the subject at the bottom of the
screen it said
13 year old
speaks out
against critical race theory
and it's sort of like you know there
there's five or six different things
that are that are wrong with this but
it it is certainly low-hanging fruit and
i think this is a difference between the
left and right you know i just pointed
out a lot of the right at this point is
doing their own version of identity
politics
but just endlessly reporting on it the
way the right does critical race theory
this mask mandate that vaccine manages
it wouldn't titillate the left the way
it would titillate the right because the
these stories create fear among the
right and more so than identity politics
and critical race theory the last six
months for the right have been
anytime masks are required or vaccines
are required go full in on it's
unconstitutional it's authoritarian etc
that's been kind of the the low effort
content generation machine for the right
for the last six months or so more so
than identity politics even yeah i would
agree you went on rogan not too long ago
did you get any backlash from the left
for that because i think bernie did
which feels sort of strangely
i know like self-defeating given that
the game is to not only hold on to the
existing voter base but to try and
actually reach new people and
rogan's nothing is not trafficking i
didn't get any backlash i went on um i
think it was like april or may
in 2020 so at the time this was before
the more anti-vaxx uh sympathetic stuff
started with rogan so i think maybe if i
were to go on now it would be different
i don't know that he would have me back
on he may be upset with me for all i
know for some of the coverage i've done
of the things he said about vaccines he
may also not have seen it i have no idea
but no when i went on i didn't get any
uh my my audience understands what i'm
doing i've done you know jesse lee
peterson's another
extreme right winger who's program i've
done and my audience gets what i'm doing
there i don't think i've ever
contacted someone on skype and had as
many contacts in common as i do with you
and oh interesting 13 mutual contacts
when i went to ring you earlier on and
the all i use this for is the show so
it's not like we happen to have like
some anti that were like half related to
were you surprised about the bernie
thing about the fact that when bernie
went on
he
he did get a bit of pushback
no i wasn't surprised i mean again i
don't i i don't remember that i remember
the big story from when bernie went on
being that rogan agreed with him on
almost everything
and it raised this question of rogan as
um what are rogan's political views or
is he a political chameleon or whatever
things that are kind of very personal
and kind of gossipy in nature but no i
mean it's not surprising that there
would be a little pushback but i don't i
don't remember it being like the big
story and obviously it made sense for
bernie to do given what was going on at
the time running a campaign yeah
has there been a sense of sort of the no
platforming or the
what we've talked about here is that
there's the left and the right seem to
be existing in two different worlds
at least narratively that the right is
focused on something that you think the
majority of the left isn't focused on
i'm not sure about your opinion for most
of the left being focused on the right
but recently we've seen ben shapiro and
anna kasparian do a debate you know i'm
aware that it's a little bit like a it's
kind of like a wwe match it wasn't just
them going out for dinner and having a
chat about something it was a big event
and broadcast and so on and so forth but
is there are we any closer to turning a
corner to actually have some more
well-meaning good faith communication
between the sides
well the thing about it is the
communication between the sides is
really easy
when you restrict the subject matter to
that on which most people would just
agree right so i think this early on was
one of the big
reasons that the intellectual dark web
so-called caught on which was
there was an there was essentially a
focus on the areas in which
those left and right wingers agreed
um mostly along the lines of
supporting free speech
opposing restrictions on speech
supporting the idea of conversations
that cross ideological and party lines
and and that's great
you know the difficulty is
when it becomes untenable to maintain
that and i think one of the reasons that
the intellectual dark web
uh and you look at search traffic for it
and the you know all these different
metrics
the reason that it's declined i think is
that
once the pandemic started
and
you saw this completely off the rails
kind of departure
from the right on a lot of basic public
health things it became untenable to get
together and be like we're we're just
all about speech
it was like an elephant in the room so
to speak it was untenable and it started
to become kind of weird like we're not
going to talk about these things
so i think that it's very easy to do
that
um when you restrict your conversation
in a way that prevents the major
disagreements i'm not saying you can't
have major disagreements politely of
course you can
but the gist of bringing everybody
together in harmony i think becomes much
more difficult
when you really get to such fundamental
ideological differences it's great to
try it of course it's a worthy effort
that's a really really interesting point
to think about the fact that one of the
reasons perhaps that the idw
worked
for a while was that the guard rails had
been brought in on what was going to be
spoken about that there is potentially
some fundamental disagreements that
people aren't going to get past but if
we if we leave those off the table
then we actually can
we can have like a performative
agreement almost and then when some
things come in that stress tested that
beyond breaking
maybe it doesn't quite work so much
yeah i mean it's like um
you know we've had these i i hope i
don't get any of these examples wrong
because i don't follow it super closely
but in thinking over the last year and a
half or two
um
for example dave rubin straight up went
i'm voting trump and i think that came
just like as a kind of shock to some
on more of the left-leaning side of the
idw
and then you had brett weinstein go very
much in on controversial
covet-related stuff about the vaccine is
toxic
and ivermectin and and different things
and that has led to sam harris to be
very critical so you know i think that
these have served as stress i hope i'm
getting them right but these are the
sorts of examples that serve as these
stress tests and it's become much more
difficult for it to remain a cohesive
group and also it may be that the
appetite for that group's continued
dialogue has declined as well i don't
know yet people only have
so many novel points of view
jordan peterson's talk and talked about
this before where he says that he gets
bored of his own voice and after a
little while you actually need to go
away and do some thinking and come back
with something novel and different
because everyone's heard what you've got
to say
yeah yeah that may be um i mean i think
yeah i don't know that i have more to
say on that but i i don't disagree with
that how would you characterize
the view of the right from
yourself at the
moment uh i think that um
the right has gone in a
very dangerous direction
over the weekend
this past or previous weekend depending
on when this airs
donald trump did another one of these
rallies this time in iowa which is an
important state for the presidential
election in the united states
and
he still did all the same things he
always does he told lies about the
pandemic he told lies about his
presidency he told lies about communism
he told lies about socialism
he had
um
black people from a group called blacks
for trump placed right on stage behind
him you know everything that's done at
every single one of these rallies
um but there was an interesting
difference which was after everything
that happened with january 6th and trump
being president when republicans lost
the house of representatives in 2018 and
then lost the senate in 2020 and lost
the white house
mainstream prominent iowa republicans
like senator chuck grassley were there
supporting trump
and it sort of
seemed to me now that we're
just over a year from the midterm
elections
um like if if they still have not said
this is too much
trump still is in control of that party
um and to me that's very scary because
the few voices in the republican party
that are willing to say
i want low taxes
and i don't like regulation
i'm not big on gay marriage you know
like all the normal stuff from like the
bush era which was bad enough but it
seems relatively it seems comparatively
milk toast although i don't want to
minimize it
liz cheney mitt romney etc
they've been pushed to the margins of
the republican party
ostracized
woman in an airport went up to mitt
romney and said i don't even think you
won your election fairly which is a very
dangerous thing now to say to anyone you
don't like you cheated and you didn't
really win that's very very dangerous
it's it's i think it's pretty bad right
now and i think you know one of the
one of the good things depending on
where you live in the united states is
that
for better and worse
the
um higher education high income higher
standard of living blue states in the
u.s
have standards of living that are
similar to norway and denmark and these
places that have robust social democracy
and so those people will probably be
mostly okay
no matter what happens at the federal
level barring
you know something really even crazier
than what we've seen
but for a lot of these folks in the
states that have
very poor financial situations
etc etc the standards of living there
are
equivalent to developing countries but
it's it's the united states i mean what
are some of those areas
um
[Music]
okay so i don't want to get any wrong
but
on education
and health care
mississippi and alabama are disasters
um
you
the information is easily accessible and
i recently did you know people can
google standard of living there's
actually something very interesting
which is
the human development index which is
normally applied to countries
there's an interesting page which does
it for us states
and finds an equivalent country and what
you see is that all these blue states in
the u.s
have stand hdi levels similar to
the social democracies of northern
europe and new zealand etc and then you
see you know the opposite for for the
red state so the information
is is available there um i think it's
really a scary situation for for large
parts of the country if
there were to be a trump part two
whether it's trump himself or someone
like ron desantis the governor of
florida etc um we're sort of lucky he
only had four years and wasn't able to
do a lot of the things he wanted to do
do you think trump is an own goal for
the right
remains to be seen
i think
a couple of data points are
trump got elected in 2016
um
2018 republicans lose the house of
representatives
2020 republicans lose the senate and
trump becomes a one-term president which
is relatively hard to do i mean i think
there have been eight or nine one-term
presidents in the u.s who ran for
re-election
typically presidents get re-elected so
that's not good
um
he didn't
build the wall
pay down the debt all the things he
promised to do right so in terms of
whether they accomplished things
i i don't know i don't even know if they
know they didn't accomplish them so so
far it's not been great
but it's created a movement that at
least for now seems to be
it continues to exist the rallies are
still very full and most republican
electeds are falling in line like i said
with chuck grassley over the weekend
so i think we need more data i think
2022 and 2024 will give us some of that
data yeah it'll be an interesting one to
see whether ron desantis does step up to
the plate with that i think it
definitely seems like that may be in the
wings if trump gets decided to be the
you say the unacceptable face
of the right it seems like ron desantis
might be the person that steps in
yeah i mean with no special insight just
looking at the straw poll data it seems
as though
right now if it's not trump desantis is
the guy that
um
republicans seem to have more of an
interest in
but i think that without seeing what
happens in 2022 it's really tough to
make any real predictions there's
something that i've noticed i want to
see if you can
if you've seen this as well
what it seems to me online when it comes
to um left-wing and right-wing
commentators content creators
it feels to me like people that are on
the right tend to react to stories that
appear within the culture so a
uh
racially segregated
graduation ceremony or a liberty tick
tock video or something like that but
very rarely actually react to content
creators on the left
whereas i see far more content creators
on the left people like yourself or kyle
kielinski or sam ceda actually doing
reaction
videos to content creators from the
right whether that be a a reuben or a
shapiro or whatever
do you have do you sort of see this
asymmetry at all or am i incorrect here
i'm not sure i'm not sure i mean i guess
if that were the case what relevance
would it have i guess would be my
question i just think it's an
interesting asymmetry why why would it
be perhaps that the left sees or some
content creators on the left find it
interesting to react to some of the
talking points that are coming out from
creators on the right but that doesn't
appear to happen in reverse i thought
that was something i'd potentially seen
online and was maybe interesting
one idea and i'm just thinking of this
now
is that over the last
certainly three
probably more like since the obama era
started
the republican party has increasingly
abandoned policy and talking about
policy
it's been more about
don't let obama do anything or undo what
obama did right obama with obamacare
voting 63 times in the house to repeal
it even though it was clearly going
nowhere this type of thing it's
obstruction and opposition
um because there's doing so little
actual policy
making or proposing of policy ideas
what we really have
to point to to explain to our audiences
what they're up to
are the things that individuals say
because
they're not actually doing the stuff
right i mean trump's build the wall
it would be the full
u.s mexico border
mexico would pay for it etc
nothing was actually happening there was
nothing actually taking place
it was trump's talk about it and then
using it to become xenophobic and all
these different things so
in a sense
because they've abandoned actual policy
what we have to look at is the things
they say they would like to do and and
that involves looking at the
personalities that that strikes me as
maybe at least part of the explanation
definitely feels like it yeah i think
that would align with what i've seen
online i mentioned it earlier on that it
it always seems to be a reaction
from the right to something that's
occurred on the left but very rarely is
a proposal
you know you listen to a lot of
right-wing commentators and it is often
here is my opinion on a story that i'm
talking about as opposed to here is an
actual proposal that moves things
forward and i see this right i see this
in the uk as well that
it it
traps the right within this constant
desire to be reactionary to let's say
it's identity politics so let's say it's
intersectionality or whatever the next
sort of outlandish story is that doesn't
actually ever get progress
it's a story that they think is so
outrageous that it's worthy of their
attention and if we don't battle back
then they're going to win and this is a
problem because it's fundamentally
taking apart whatever it is that we care
about
but that doesn't allow you to progress
you're constantly playing defense
constantly playing defense and never
actually proposing anything
yeah i think that the exceptions would
be things like
the incredibly restrictive abortion
bills sometimes they're called like
heartbeat bills or whatever the case may
be
those do put the left in a position to
really have to activate um
including through the court system and
and in other ways
because that really has like a tangible
immediate impact on people right away in
the real world but with that as an
exception
um i tend to think that that you're
mostly right
usually the left would be quite averse
to big pharma
typically i think and yet we've seen
them
they're aligned because of the
requirement the view that there is a
requirement for people to get vaccinated
are you surprised by this at all are you
surprised by the fact that big pharma at
the moment is sort of an acceptable
how's it seen is it an acceptable evil
how's it how's it working
no my view on this is that um
[Music]
that you're sort of mixing two different
things
so first there's the perception of big
pharma
which um
i don't see as having changed at all
from the left but remember the the
vaccine requirements don't come from big
pharma so really we're talking about two
different things here
um
when it comes to big pharma
my view is that
there is no question that the profit
motive
plays a major role
in this industry how could it not of
course it does
that's very different
than there would be any reason
to profit from a vaccine that
doesn't work that
harms people
that
whatever right so so these these are
sort of two different things a lot of
money was made
from developing the vaccines
but
is that the worst thing in the world
assuming people get access to a vaccine
that works i mean when we think about
the things people can make money for you
know there's this couple
from biontech that developed the vaccine
turkish immigrants to germany that
ultimately became what we know as the
pfizer vaccine
and sometimes people will point out do
you really want that vaccine those
people made a ton of money
well they did an amazing thing didn't
they
i mean if anybody deserves to be well
compensated wouldn't it be someone who
develops a vaccine in this period of
time that helps us
dramatically reduce the risk of serious
illness and death so for me it's not
about the analysis of big pharma we know
the limitations of big pharma we
understand
the fda and
the fda mostly getting it right and
occasionally getting it wrong and on all
these different things i see that as
separate from the requirement or mandate
issue
which is primarily uh not actually about
the vaccine i mean remember
a third of the vaccine hesitant
before the approval of the pfizer
vaccine said as soon as it's approved
fully i'll go and get it
and at the time i said no they're lying
they're going to move the goal post to
something else once it's approved
they'll say now the approval isn't
trustworthy a couple months ago fda
issued a full approval
that's exactly what they did i mean
within within hours fox news was saying
was this vaccine approved too quickly
was the process rushed by the fda for
political reasons
so i i see these as two separate things
and i don't see the mandates
or requirements really connected to
one's opinion of big pharma at large
what's the vaccine rate in the us at the
moment
do you know i think for fully vaccinated
it's somewhere between 55 and 58
i think not a lot then
no no i mean really at this point i
think last among what would be called
wealthy countries
and behind many not wealthy countries as
well it's really it's really humiliating
quite frankly i think we're 80
in the 80s maybe even 87 percent
in the uk
that may be for first dose not for full
course it would be worth checking
sometimes one is reported sometimes the
other is reported but there's no
question that the numbers are way higher
in the uk without a doubt yeah it's
crazy another thing i was listening to
your episode with with rogan a little
while ago and on it this was the one
from 2020 so
um no concerns real concerns about
vaccine hesitancy yet there was no
vaccine
and in it you were talking about the
potential of trump having another term
and repealing roe vs wade and one of the
things that came up there was
removing bodily autonomy
from people um and restricting uh bodily
autonomy i can do what i want with with
my body i should be able to have the
choice but with the vaccine this year
and vaccine mandates it seems like
that's a that's a little bit of a pivot
is that something at all that you've a
circle that you've been able to square
so to speak like is that a continuous
line of thought that you can see there
yeah no it's there's no there's no uh
controversy whatsoever in my mind
um if you don't want to get vaccinated
in just about every case you can opt out
and be tested instead
there are some organizations
um that are under the purview of the
federal government or in specific
situations where the employer has said
we don't want to deal with the opt-out
testing
so
if you want to work here you have to be
vaccinated
and you have the choice as to whether
you want to work there or not you know
the only real the only real exception is
the military
and you can still leave the military but
the military has a long history of these
are the vaccines you get when you join
the military
um and they've added the covet 19
vaccine in addition to like six to ten
others or something like that
um
any and even then you could you could
leave the military so no i mean no
nobody's being forced you know this the
very same right that loves to say
employers should have freedom to
organize employment however they want
and employees have the freedom to accept
or not accept a job based on anything do
they like the hours do they like their
boss do they like their office do they
like the vaccine requirements
um
everybody can make the choices that that
they want and i don't see any issue
whatsoever
who or what do you think are the biggest
problems on the left at the moment if
you were able to wave a magic wand and
get people to focus less on certain
things and focus more on other things
i think the the way i would generally
call it would be just the perfect
becoming the enemy of the better
and i'm not the one who has you know
come up with that that idea but it's
sometimes uh narrow disagreements within
the left
distracting or spending political
capital and preventing any progress at
all
uh seeding ground to the right or even
giving giving the opportunity to the
right to get things done or to prevent
the left from doing things because the
left can't be
totally on the same page
litmus tests on the left i think
sometimes can be problematic
where
if we agree on nine things but not this
tenth thing we can't even work on the
nine things we do agree on
i think that type of ideology is is
problematic i don't i wouldn't be able
to name people that are problematic on
the left i the people
if i see someone on the left that's
problematic i just kind of don't follow
them
and do my own thing
um there's just so much to read and pay
attention to that i try not to waste my
time with that but yeah i think the
inability sometimes to say
here's an area where we agree
and we all agree
as to something that would be better
than what the right wants let's get it
done oh no but we disagree on this other
thing that's not really an issue here
that that doesn't seem good that seems
like a problem has that always been the
case or is that a new phenomenon
i don't know that it's been it's it's
always been the case to some degree i
mean even back in the progressive era of
the late 19th century into the 1915s
1920s there was some degree of that in
the new deal era the under fdr there
were there was some of that
it feels as though it's worse right now
but it's that's not based on anything
empirical that i've researched deeply um
yeah it's uh
it's a strange one to think about that
one of the things that keeps on coming
up are these sort of two narratives that
are existing online at the moment where
one person sees one view for instance i
was listening to one of your episodes or
a segment that you did on a teacher
who was at home
hadn't gone into school and had told
everybody why she wasn't going into
school and it was because there was a
mandate to get vaccinated and she wasn't
going to and then
she
tested is an important detail she could
have just said no vaccine but i'm going
to be tested she was refusing that as
well and then she bro signs her way
through a bunch of research that she'd
done herself and so on and so forth and
yet if i was to watch
a show from the right i would also see
examples of teachers that were
forcing children to have masks or
screaming at a girl or there's a girl
that's in detention i saw a girl
handcuffed in her school hallway the
other day because she wasn't wearing so
again this isn't just about the social
media
uh the how would you say the fragmentary
nature of social media but just the fact
that there are such different worlds
that people exist in at the moment so
for someone that's trying to make sense
of both sides
it doesn't surprise me that it's
difficult it doesn't surprise me that
i'm coming to you and asking basic [ __ ]
questions because i'm like
i see
i can see two completely polar opposite
and both of these
are true or they both appear to be true
so
meshing those together is a function of
how big your country is which is massive
so you're always going to have tons and
tons of outliers on both sides but it's
very difficult to work out some sort of
a middle ground like how do you zero off
that set of accounts i can see a girl
who's been handcuffed because like a
young girl who's been handcuffed because
she hasn't worn her mask in school and
then there's this teacher that's saying
that the vaccines got blah blah blah
spike proteins in it that are dangerous
like
it's really confusing it's a very
confusing landscape to exist in it's
confusing but i think it's not accurate
to mesh all these things together
equally so let's see if we can
disaggregate some of them
the girl getting handcuffed
police in schools and the school to
prison pipeline is a major issue in the
united states
about which the right has mostly not
cared about for decades
until
it started to have to do with masks and
vaccines so i find the right's view on
police doing i'm i'm with them
shouldn't be handcuffing a little girl
shouldn't be handcuffing a 12 year old
in school we have these stories all the
time
i care about all of them because of the
presence of police in schools and
how that
seems to be a very negative experience
and influence for children
um the right hasn't cared about that for
decades until right now i find their
view on it very very cynical now let's
get to the other examples
you've got the video of the teacher
who says
i'm not in school
because they're trying to get me that
get vaccinated and i'm not going to do
it
or they need me to get tested and i'm
also not going to do that and air
which is what she said she says oxygen
cures coronavirus
on the other hand
a teacher
trying to enforce the the rule that the
school has which is you got to wear a
mask
and getting frustrated and yelling i
don't like that the teacher got
frustrated i don't like that the teacher
yelled
but there's no equivalency
to a teacher spreading obvious dangerous
disinformation about oxygen curing the
virus and no one needing to be
vaccinated or be tested so i just don't
see them as equivalent no i would agree
i mean there's tons and tons of videos
whether it's
that really disturbing video of a
toddler that kept on having the mask
pulled down over their face which almost
seemed performative to me that almost
seemed like it was staged that i didn't
see that one
uh there's a little child
three years old four years old
presumably some sort of daycare or
nursery that needed to have a mask on
and then the child kept pulling it off
and someone an adult kept forcibly
pulling it down and it was like a it's a
60-second video of constantly this child
being pulled down it's obviously in
distress obviously doesn't want it and
it was so sort of flagrant that it i
genuinely was i was like really
skeptical about whether or not that was
legit it's quite uncomfortable to watch
um i mean um that may be i guess the
question when i see a video like that is
okay so there's a kid struggling to put
a mask on and that that's sad and i'm
sure if i saw the video i wouldn't like
the way the kids be from if it's though
the kids got the mask on and then wants
to pull it off so the kid pulls it down
and then continues to be to have it put
back on presumably the narrative is that
it's it needs to have it done i'm sure
my reaction to that video would be the
same as your reaction or any kind of you
know reasonable empathetic person i
think the question is sort of like on
the basis of that video does that tell
us anything about in general what policy
should be
and i think that that's where it can get
kind of dangerous where people will use
that video to say
any any number of different things like
what we know is absent being able to be
vaccinated and ventilation and all these
different things
the schools that are that are requiring
masks have lower rates of spread do we
think they're that it's worth it then
that's a question for everybody to kind
of judge but i think where it can get
dicey is
okay there's a horrible video of this
kid who doesn't want to wear the mask
okay
but so what does this mean about policy
the masks still do reduce the spread
absent vaccination we probably should be
using them in school
so i think
what we extrapolate from it is where we
open up ourselves to sort of fallacious
thinking and this is the problem of
having the most
gregarious ridiculous or eye-catching
content that gets the most reach like
that's something that's difficult for
people to ignore because it's quite an
uncomfortable watch
but as you say it doesn't actually
necessarily contribute to moving a
conversation forward not in a productive
way so
is there anything at the moment what's
your
view moving forward you know you are
for better or worse sort of close to the
eye of the storm when it comes to
content creation and and being online
and sort of swimming through these
waters do you think that there's going
to be an improvement in ability to
communicate is it going to get worse
any ideas
it could go either way and you know
predictions are worth
very very little in my mind you know my
focus will continue to be
just explaining what the facts are
and also explaining what count as facts
so this has been a this is like an
epistemic problem in the u.s
if we say here is the science of what
vaccines do
and here's someone who says i have a
different opinion about what vaccines do
that's not equivalent and unfortunately
there's a group of people that think it
is equivalent so it's not even about the
disagreement it's about the idea that
both types of statements
are statements to be compared
um so i'm going to do everything i can
to communicate what the facts are with
an interest in getting past this
pandemic of course
but more generally about the
conversations i'm not super optimistic
maybe on a different day i maybe i'm
having more of a pessimistic day today
another day i would be more optimistic
but
no i mean having spoken to experts in
conspiracism
cult-like thinking
radicalization etc it's really really
tough
to get people out of this type of
thinking and some people use the term
deprogram we don't have to use that word
it can take
over months building a relationship
one-on-one with people and that might
work as
a like small numbers type of thing
but that's not really going to get you
like the big cultural awareness shift
that we would need to
for example get everybody vaccinated
right so that's that's where my lack of
optimism comes from
man thank you i really really enjoyed
this there's certainly some
interesting mental models that i've
taken away the lack of equivalency or
there's not always two equal sides to
one story is
definitely something that i think i'll
use to try and be more effectively
skeptical
certainly also thinking about
the fact that then what you see online
isn't always representative especially
when what you're seeing is second hand
passed to you by other creators i think
both of those
are really important sort of sense
making tools and you had a quote uh
talking about richard spencer you said
it's not about who you have on it's how
you treat them
and i think that
it's not necessarily about just the
stuff that you consume it's about how
you can filter that through and i think
that that sort of those sense making
tools can be can be pretty useful so if
people want to keep up to date with what
you do and catch more of your content
where should they go yeah
davidpakman.com links out to everything
we've got uh we've got the youtube
channel uh we're on tick tock now
twitter you know all the different
things but davidpakman.com is uh is the
great place and just one other idea just
to build on what you said about the two
sites thing
sometimes people get mixed up through
no fault of their own between neutrality
and objectivity
and these are two very different things
and and often there's the idea that
it's neutral for example to bring on one
person who accepts the science of
climate and one person who denies it and
it's like it's neutral we're
representing both sides equally but
there's nothing objective about that in
terms of how it relates to what's known
and so i think in the same
whenever we're thinking about this these
equivalencies and and sides
neutrality and objectivity are two very
different things and just because
something looks or appears neutral or we
have an instinct to want to find neutral
ground we should ask whether we're
actually being objective in doing so
because sometimes the facts are just on
one side and being neutral is not
objective in any way that's an
interesting point to dig into that a
little bit a little bit more
one of the challenges that everybody has
and that's everyone that's an audience
member and also a content creator is
that every choice you make is an
editorial decision yes every single word
that mean you have said to each other
throughout this entire conversation has
been an editorial decision do i want to
continue to chase you down about one
particular branch of that tree or do i
want to come back toward the main thrust
of the conversation and keep going down
a lot of the time
we will both be criticized for not
pushing back against one particular
thing but if you were to push back
against every single element of a
conversation it would be so fractured
that you wouldn't get anywhere and it
would be a disgusting thing to listen to
so every single time you do that the
same thing goes for let's say that we're
talking about um climate scientists so
for instance good example i had a guy
called patrick [ __ ] who used to be the
president of greenpeace and he is a
climate scientist but he is very
skeptical in two months time i have
richard betts who is the head of the uk
government international uh
intergovernmental panel on climate
change the ipcc
i have both of those guys on
i am not a climate scientist
should i not have this conversation
until i'm able to
uh assess both of their levels of
science up to up to a degree where i can
know exactly what's going on well that's
going to take me years and years and
years to be able to do so again that's
an editorial decision that is
constrained by the fallibility of being
humans
it's a challenge i think in that case
you know i think responsible platforming
is what i advocate for so obviously
it would be unreasonable to expect you
to have the same level of expertise as
all of your guests in every topic it's
an impossibility
um
but i think what would apply would be
um
being able to responsibly
push back
against
what may be bad arguments being spread
by some of these folks like when i
interviewed richard spencer versus when
others did i made every effort to be
ready to
responsibly rebut the claims that that
he would make no i don't think you need
to be an expert
in those fields but certainly if it were
me so that i don't get snowed by these
folks with bad science or bad ideas
or non-science would be to know what
they're likely to say and to understand
what the rebuttals are at minimum as a
parent
yeah i agree man i i really appreciate
the work that you do in this space i
think that being someone that is
genuinely coming across in a good faith
way and trying to remain objective and
also as a good role model for people to
think okay this is a way that you can
have a conversation with someone where
you can perhaps bring on people with
differing points of views or points of
views that your audience may
disagree with or struggle with and then
using that as an opportunity to stress
test that and also i'm sure it's an
enjoyable experience for yourself as
well to go right okay i'm going to test
my metal i'm going to put my ideas my
counter id is up against this person's
ideas yeah i think it's it's good work
man i really appreciate talking to you
today thank you i really appreciate you
having me on
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace